[Applause]
hello flow fill up a little loop hey
guys how are you how are you it's a
question so if you have one it's a good
time to raise your hand good I don't
know you pick you pick get what's your
name
with anyone from history or fictional
Randy the Macho Man Savage I mean he
really legitimately like obviously the
real the honestly answered that question
is I lost both my grandfather's before I
got to know them and I think that would
be cool but no question outside of like
family members macho man like wrestling
was so culturally relevant in that
period of time and I'm so
anti-establishment it's so funny I can
put on a sport and like one o'clock in
the morning know nothing about it and
the second I understand who's the
favorite and who's the underdog I'm like
my life depends on the underdog winning
and Hulk Hogan was so ridiculously
blindly adored that I had to go all
macho man all the time so that's my guy
next question
yeah you you pander to the Google
ecosystem of the mid-2000s right I
wouldn't I wouldn't scrap it I would
start establishing the brand in parallel
you know it's really funny my dad had a
liquor store named shoppers discount
liquors for 20 years there was 20 of
them in Jersey it was a brand for liquor
stores in Jersey when we when we started
winelibrary.com
we didn't change the stores name for
three and a half years there was a sign
in the front door when you'd walk in
that would say winelibrary.com
but we migrated into the brand you don't
need to feel the pain
although lost that juice that you've
built up for the last decade but I would
say something like you know Denver
escape rooms brought to you by the
escape hunt and everything because got
it so I would transition into it and
rightfully so you need to transition it
to it yesterday
guys Google search an SEO is in deep
[ __ ]
ten years from today everybody in this
room will be doing eighty percent of
their searching 90% of their searching
by voice don't believe me I was also
telling people they want to do phone
calls anymore and they would be texting
eight years ago and you know that's how
you roll now it seems crazy
it seems ludicrous until you see that
every single nine-year-old on earth only
searches a voice typing search result
ISM is in the early stages of its demise
and if you're built on that if you rely
on that you don't have to scrap it you
have to start building other moats
because you will be in trouble thank you
very much
and
[Music]
you know it's interesting Lex I think
I'm a very big believer that losing and
adversity is the best thing that can
happen to you so when that questions
asked where my mind goes is more like
[ __ ] I wouldn't want to give up that the
Elle's the losses or the context I mean
if you know if I went back and well you
know what would I tell myself or what
what did I wish I know like Flo I don't
know I would have bought Amazon stock
for a dollar you know like like there's
a but as far as like life whereas you
started barking in your next chapters I
think the biggest thing that people that
are young struggle with is lack of
patience and I don't think there's a
close second everybody is so quick you
know why because when you're 22 you
either you're stuck trying to prove
something to somebody whether it's to
yourself which is really the best but
for 99 percent it's to prove to your
parent to a buddy to your friend
net-like it's patience you know why
but it's you know the questions that
you're really asking is when you value
somebody else's opinions you start
taking shortcuts because you're trying
to speed up proving to somebody else
when you're in your own [ __ ] you've got
your whole life to do it right
the company
[Music]
[Applause]
by the way your what you're working way
too slow I'm serious do 240 thousand
dollars a month prorated top-line
revenue as long as your and I can just
from your vibe I know you're not buying
dumb [ __ ] you're you're walking two
founders dilemmas you're you're doing
cliche [ __ ] you are fewer months behind
your first employees you need to have
other employees okay
like yesterday yes not trends you're
keeping too much money you need to spend
it on people you need to stop using your
ego from slowing you down they may start
as an eight point three or to your point
it might be a three you've got to get
over that hump you will lose
I think that sees a very good place you
know I've been fond of Pepsi for a long
time but again let me answer your
question in a smarter way that helps
everybody if you were dependent on one
platform you are in [ __ ] trouble
[Music]
you know what's crazy people don't
realize it's ego that's stopping you
good check your [ __ ] ego at the door
and higher say that's what it is but by
the way real quick so many people here
that are you let me rephrase so many
people in the game right now are so
dependent on Instagram it scares the
[ __ ] outta me please always do what I do
which is tomorrow you wake up and it's
gone what does that mean and if it means
you're in trouble you need to start
diversifying yesterday cool who's next
[Music]
you don't you you know like when things
are you like how does Wine Library ship
wine to Massachusetts it doesn't like
legalities are a friction so you know if
you can't do an activity you don't and
you find ways to figure out how to do
that activity so what about moving
[Music]
well can you run
can you run free information that has no
commerce attached to it yeah well that's
called branding yeah so you could do it
not selling education branding
yes that's exactly right you see where
I'm going you're not gonna run an ad to
do a sale you're gonna make a piece of
you need to make a three-minute video
about the benefits of or did you know or
what's going on
you're gonna mark in not sell even the
way that you asked it it's really it's
just a text unbelievably interesting
insight you're in the mindset of the
selling part that you can't do but
you're but you're not prohibited from
the branding if there's no ask there's
no cell so you're establishing brand so
that when you can layer the ask it's
just one huge [ __ ] jab waiting
correct got it
yes
I got it
a hundred percent because it's
all-encompassing right and the audience
will go with you right like people are
so scared to show other parts of that
it's like everybody here who's casual in
their LinkedIn photo puts themselves in
a suit and tie like you can be you they
will come to you right yes and you can
post and by the way putting a post about
you skiing this weekend or that you love
peanut butter is a tremendous off-speed
pitch as well everybody you're still in
the same fastball over and over I'm
actually it's gonna get hit so like
we're mixing it up like matters exactly
take a picture of some scrambled eggs
and say [ __ ] yummy
[Music]
hey brother how are you thank you
I'm super-pumped I need battery packs
thank you thank you how to use the
denver again this is true if you're a
hardcore football fan al toons career
ended in denver he took a hit in the
head and it was it pretty much the end
of his career
[Music]
[Music]
good even following people do more of it
I mean just news alert in 2007 to 2011 I
spent 15 hours a day talking to people
on Twitter every day go look guys either
you have your time and work ethic or you
have money
it's not super complicated you have your
time ambition and look I think go to
sleep an hour earlier or later excuse me
like I don't know work more like you you
know the rabbit like it's just how long
is the business been around but you've
got to define fast my opinion Pete how
old are you right perfect I'm 42 as well
the reason he laughed and not in the bad
way is I'm telling you back to Lexington
I'm telling you guys it's patience your
business is [ __ ] in a second old bro
like like I don't even want to ever talk
to you again for another six years and
then and that I can't wait what I'm
telling you you're gonna be seeing me
soon is the biggest reason I don't think
I'm gonna be seeing you soon and I'm not
trying to rouse I love you the altoon
thing we're friends already but but I
need everybody to really wrap their
[ __ ] head around this I'm gonna make
it very clear I on my children's health
I believe I'm just starting on my
children's health
I am so early in the process it will
make your head spin cool nice things are
happening I understand from where I'm
going what I'm actually up to I'm in the
first inning being see you soon this and
that even that question is completely
inappropriate coming from love this
early on like a lot more organic like a
lot more like 20 hours a day if you want
it that bad because the alternatives
you're gonna go work somewhere right so
to me it's like people like man but like
when I tell them 18 hours of community
management huh searching hashtags
putting out content more videos I put
out 147 pieces of content a week you
know but like I did way more tweets when
it was just me and my phone and it
wasn't [ __ ] Twitter was even mobile I
forgot
that's hopping like like the answers a
lot more my biggest piece of advice is
that you think in 10 and 20 and 30 year
terms for real not just in a tweet not
just to be here right now your actions
let me just say one more time because I
need somebody I know I need somebody to
hear and hear from the day I started
running that wine business at 22 years
old so I was 30 for 12 years I worked 15
hours a day six for seven days a week in
a liquor store 12 years in a row 15
hours a day in a liquor store 15 hours a
day
had no social life never paid myself
over 150,000 a year left at 34 to start
with AJ vaynermedia had 0% ownership of
Wine Library which means I have no
collateral to get a loan or any leverage
with a bank for anything in business and
had no money in my bank account I was 34
I'd already built a 60 million dollar
business not for myself
that's called patience so when I spit it
to you
I'm not coming from hypocrisy or a high
course I live it I will even millions of
dollars on the table every year for
patients the answers a lot more
[Applause]
yeah pretty shirt shirt Thanks
I got a one question you know earlier
today she talked about Facebook social
media we still do a lot with the TV
radio we do a lot of Facebook we have a
company that does all that stuff would
you recommend us going off the social
media bullying abydos I can't really
quantify anything that we get from
magazines TV radio so for the next
twenty
so let's talk about the best way to go
what how much are you spending across
the channels and how much of each
channel we probably spend and what do
you what's the Africa media Facebook and
how's that working we're working with
the qualifier I know
but so why are you why are you doing TV
and radio print I thought it was the way
build awareness yes so Facebook's
awareness play is much better than TV
and radio and all that stuff you just
have to make awareness creative so the
10,000 you're spending is it kind of
like is a couponing incentivizing call
this or is it more just like videos of
how rad it is that people come exactly
good my intuition
my intuition is I would move the 10,000
for the other stuff to Facebook you're
welcome good luck who's next
people are so infatuated with what's
next they don't focus on what's actually
happening don't worry about voice don't
worry about augmented reality
don't worry about blockchain don't worry
about anything your tiny business just
you know attack Facebook I'm not even a
even would want most of you to not even
have to do Instagram though I love it
for branding and being contemporary
Facebook is so [ __ ] effective once
you figure it out now it and by the way
you can tweak it eight million ways the
same way that long tail search was a
thing right it's and creative is the
variable like the picture in the video
is the punchline not the ad Facebook was
great for the math kids because all blue
letters right excuse me google was great
because it was all blue letters Facebook
stuff cuz its pictures and videos you
actually have to make a good commercial
and that's what's [ __ ] everybody up
do focus a follow me on Facebook
[Music]
listenmi you are so an outer [ __ ]
space right now I don't want you to say
any word ever again besides Facebook yes
Jade blockchains like 13 years away from
being at scale and impacting our
day-to-day like if you want to do spec
Theory Amman Bitcoin and doge coin
buying knock yourself out
but like [ __ ] like buy some [ __ ]
facebook ads yes thank you
you